Here, the correct answers were 1 plus or minus root 3, all divided by 2. You
may have listed your answer as 1 half plus or minus root 3 divided by 2. These
would be correct as well. To solve this equation, we need to first start by
setting it equal to 0. So we'll subtract 1 from both sides. We identify a, b,
and c using the coefficients in front of each term. a is positive 2, b is
negative 2, and c is negative 1. We do the negative of b, which would be
positive 2, and then, plus or minus b squared minus 4ac, all divided by 2a. We
simplify our answer by cleaning up this radical to get 2 plus or minus root 4
plus 8, all divided by 4. Negative 2 squared is 4 here. And negative 4 times 2
times negative 1 is positive 8. This radical simplifies to root 12, which is 2
times root 3. These two terms share a common factor of 2, so we can rewrite our
numerator as 2 times 1 plus or minus 1 root 3. We notice that the numerator and
denominator share a common factor of 2, so we simplify that to 1, leaving us
with this expression.